this is part 2 of turning my
Weird Barbie of a downstairs hallway
into something functional
and maybe not totally hideous
the concrete blocks that you can see was
actually the old exterior of the house
before they built the extension
some 60 odd years ago which is why there's a window in it
*was* a window in it
cause she really needed to go
I did have a couple of comments from people in part 1
which I've linked in the caption telling me
that I should have saved the window
and aside from the fact that that glass was old and brittle as hell
and we've got kids constantly running around here
so it could be a hazard
just having a window in the middle of an interior wall is weird to me
it makes no design sense and it means I can't use the wall for other things
so it had to go
once we had finished simply demolishing, prewiring
insulating, framing
GIBing, plastering
Panelling, sanding and priming
then we were finally ready to paint
and I chose this unsurprisingly controversial colour
called Tiki Tiki from Dulux
if you know me
you know that prior to moving in here
I spent three years living in a sad beige new build of my own making
this house is a beautiful big mid century home and she really suits colour
I think she would be an autumn or a winter girlie
cause she just looks so good in the jewel tones
I played around with different colours in the past here
and she's definitely not a pastel girlie
which means we need to be all in without colour or all out
I don't make the rules, she does
but did you know that crimson in interiors was super popular
from mid 40s to mid 60s, right around the time that this house was built?
and there's a few reasons behind that apparently anyway
it had its moment for like 30 years
and then it fell out of fashion for another 60
but I think we're seeing a resurgence
and maybe I'm just looking for confirmation bias
but I'm definitely seeing it everywhere
it's all over my Pinterest feed
and it's in just about every interiors article that I read
So I know it's not just me saying that Crimson is making a comeback
so I thought I might try it out in my home and see if I like it
and I know not everyone's gonna like it
I already heard you in Part 1 but that's okay
you don't have to like it
I fkn love it. it's giving old money red
it's giving heritage
it's giving not afraid to try new things and I'm here for it plus
it's just paint if I ever get sick of it
I can change it
somebody asked me how we do the capping at the top
so this is how
I stand here and supervise while my husband puts these two bits of wood up
then it was time to finish the wall with a nice big thick skirt
I love using big thick skirting boards in this home
because that's what all of the original areas had
and it feels like a bit of an homage to time gone by
which is kinda all I wanna do here
our amazing sparkies came back to do the final fit off
and we did have to wait a little bit to get our hands on these copper lights
but I think it was worth it
quick reminder of where we started
and this is where we ended up
It’s still not done because eventually we're gonna replace the carpet
and I still need to decorate obviously
I'm gonna turn this space into Memory Lane
with family photos all the way along
and this is just hallway phase 1
cause it's gonna take us a bit of time to get it up the stairs
and right to the front door
but yeah what do you think so far?